north stream one pipeline shutdown has
left europe on the edge
the question is if it will switch it
back on
is europe gonna get the gas it needs
this winter
on july 11th russia shut down nord
stream one the biggest pipeline carrying
russian gas to germany went into
maintenance
the works are routine procedure every
year but the war has many asking whether
moscow will keep the pipeline off
[Music]
of
a sudden end to russian gas deliveries
would be a nightmare scenario say german
politicians
germany relies on russia for around a
third of its gas imports
in industry gas is essential in many
production purposes
and half of german households use it to
heat their homes
[Music]
in february
that's claudia kempfat one of germany's
leading environmental and energy experts
she says four things are now important
this is just
australia
berlin has been scrambling to get some
of these measures in motion
since russia's invasion of ukraine
germany has reduced its dependence on
russian gas
the government has also given the
go-ahead for two lng terminals to be
built
four floating terminals have also been
secured to process lng
two are set to come online by the end of
the year
and by mid-july germany had raised its
gas storage levels to almost 65 per cent
largely because the government decided
not to use gas for electricity
production anymore
the politics alistar ferdinand
the government wants to set up a gas
auction model to incentivize the saving
of gas by industry but if west comes to
worst harbeck has indicated that gas
supply for certain industries could be
prioritized over domestic households
germany hopes to no longer be dependent
on russian gas
by spring 2024
in the meantime renewable energies have
also gotten a big boost
over easter the government agreed to
reserve two percent of the country's
surface area for onshore wind power
more than twice the area currently
designated
but there have also been setbacks for
germany's climate goals
the government has decided to leave its
coal plants running longer than planned
to sustain energy supply but also to
counter rising energy costs for german
consumers and businesses
nuclear power might also be back on the
table in the coming weeks energy
providers will run a stress test for the
electric grid
this will determine whether power
supplies can be guaranteed this winter
even if there are severe disruptions
berlin says they will analyze whether
leaving those facilities running longer
could help boost energy security
energy prices were already soaring
before the war in ukraine began
inflation was rising due to supply chain
disruptions caused by the kobit 19
pandemic
but the war in ukraine has exacerbated
the global macroeconomic outlook
a sudden end to russian gas deliveries
to europe's industrial powerhouse
germany now would ripple across the
continent
not just because they rely on russian
energy themselves but also because of
germany's economic significance
you will see very dramatic increases in
natural gas prices and you will have
outright shortages
in the european economies as we look
forward into the winter
to avoid any shortages and disruptions
the eu recently agreed to raise its
reserve gas storage to 80 by november
but more coordination efforts will be
needed
this could for instance mean that you
know there is a clear decision taken
that okay we're going to prioritize the
you know supply of a gas for heating
houses in slovakia but that means we
need to turn down or ration the supply
for say the basf plant in lubbock's half
that's the kind of thing that can only
be coordinated
through the eu
berlin has already signed solidarity
agreements with its european neighbours
like with austria
this would avoid lengthy negotiations in
cases of emergency
eu countries may need to stick together
more to stay warm over this winter